you
mr. cube fanatic yay
fine let's try d4 again why not why not
they're typing hopefully their stream is
muted very cool I figured you would do
just that
very nice all right let's go once again
Queen's Gambit let's go with Queen c2
I'm not so quick to just play a gambit
sohow pawn takes Queen takes and now mm
all right let's get him out there Bishop
f5 is now gonna come with tempo 2 which
I'll reply Queen to b3 all right and hit
at this point so there's that little
give-and-take let's get my knight out a
little give-and-take Bishop here hits
the queen but weakens this square Bishop
here Queen b3 Queen b6 c5 mm-hmm I might
want to play c5 myself if a 4 there's a
five-night a6 to b4 I'm not so sure I
want to give up my B 4 square so easily
so what can I do well for starters I
think this is fine there might be takes
takes and now b5 maybe I should have
done a Brook move first yeah I'm
thinking instead of making the bishop
move I should have done this I think
okay Wow all right I'm gonna play here
I'm assuming well this is a little bit
awkward now how do you defend this for K
7 yeah that's tricky now isn't it okay
hmm hmm Castle yeah I'm not afraid I'm
not afraid of this take here b5 I'm
going to drop back and eventually I'll
play a 4 there might be a way to soon
exploit the rook position on a7 h3 is
something I will eventually do maybe
black could try to run after the bishop
pair the knife for Bishop exchange
Knight there is another move
all right let's get here opposite the
Queen I'm also watching over this square
so that there's if my knight goes
elsewhere there's not going to be any
Knight d2 moves which would normally
which would be a fork so my rook is
there to defend Oh actually am I not
just winning this pawn okay you have to
do that in between move first but now we
have either a a backward pun if I take
with my queen this pawn needs to take
and then I have good control over the c5
I take with this well it's not best so I
have everything I could really want from
this position I have my [ __ ] up outside
my pawn chain he's not really going to
be able to contribute much and I control
the only opened file I'm hang on for a
second am I really needed on d1 maybe
maybe it's still okay I was thinking
keep him on a1 and maybe this is still a
possibility a4 but if I if there's only
one file and I have control over it
I don't think it's necessary to run
further with opening new files so let's
just keep it as is let's create a flight
square if Knight here I'm gonna box him
out immediately with b3 I do not want to
play move like b4 because then this file
will be shot down in the dark with
Knight b6 here so let's make sure he's
not going to do anything great in fact I
already missed something you know and I
saw this okay it's still available
Bishop to c6 is winning the night I had
that one move sooner and I saw it before
that knight move I don't know I got
sidetracked talking about boxing out the
knight Bishop c7 the best thing you
could do here is just take because he's
going to drop soon so it's better to
play this position down the exchange
then simply down a night where there is
no imbalance it's better to create an
imbalance than to just be down a flat
piece so this Knight is still having a
difficult time doing anything and I am
welcome to more and more trades that's
the plan from here I'm on this pawn he
might get trapped if east six this
Bishop is short on
where's stuff like moving the night f3g
for stuff it's not easy to like free up
the bishop along this diagonal either
because after the night move I have
pressure on H five okay I'm fine with
simply coming back over here we're not
coming back over but let's just get him
working he's not needed on this closed D
file anymore I'm not sure he really ever
was needed there okay how do I keep it
really really simple I don't want to
create any sort of complications
clockwise or position wise so how can i
facilitate more exchanges well how about
this as a start
rook here I'm looking to take and then
take on a six and once a six falls this
Bishop comes right to life so it's
difficult this pawn structure alone the
d4 III structure negates this push up
and so I'm still looking to come back
here and hunt down this a6 pawn these
are two unprotected pieces let's throw a
rock on the same rank let's get on the
same rank if possible of the night and
pawn to 45 less than 214 black I really
don't have any worries from this
position because I have I haven't under
control the material gain it's tough to
well okay so this Bishop might end up
getting trapped like I was saying but
let's let's just go hunt down this
Knight and grab this pawn and then on b5
I think my opponent might be close to
resigning because I'm going to end up
with connected past pawns and still be
up the exchange knowing full well I
could of course still just give back
material at any point if things get a
little too crazy and just to release any
pressure that might be placed on my
position but not quite sure I even see
that happening from here he's kind of a
dead piece on g7 okay it's at that point
you're resigned
all right good game let's go back yeah
that night that it's a the structure
change it was really the the biggest
thing here let's just go back into the
game game history right here and let's
look from your perspective so anything
strike me is a little bit odd
well this move here a six I don't think
it ties in well from this position like
right here hmm because I get to play
Queen b3 and this is awkward you don't
really want to I mean I've seen some
lines with this but it's not this
position where this rook a seven move
takes place so I think there's an
adjustment already needed
I wonder if after g6 hang on let's back
up
I played pawn up here Bishop f4 maybe at
this point you play Bishop f5 and you
meet Queen b3 with Queen b6 this just
seems far too weakening the ACE I mean
another thing is that when you do have a
six in after Bishop f5 Queen b3 you
would really like to play b5 at this
moment here maybe you still could but
this file is going to open up and I'm
going to be the one who benefits
my Knights are on their classic squares
still a little bit awkward for you
Knight to do anything and this structure
again here really does a good job of
knocking him out of the game the bishop
on g7 is simply biting at Iraq if there
isn't an e5 or c5 move e5 is certainly
all the more difficult to get in since
these natural deployments of the minor
pieces control that Square so if
anything there's this c5 break but it's
it's really tough to do something with
the Queen Knight and on top of that I
didn't point this out during the game
what do you really do with the Queen
she's kind of stuck it's a this slight
space advantage I have here of course we
have both have one pawn in the center
but I have you know a little bit more
space I have my C pawn contributing in a
slight
more aggressive way then of course the
seasick spawn which is strictly
defensive I have the options of
capturing or pushing it's tough it's
tough to get this last piece out and
finding us and find a safe Square for
the Queen so this was unfortunate rook
to a7 I think at that point I was
considering this but I didn't see any
reason to break the tension just a
complete development rook to d1 b5 takes
takes yeah you have to do that in
between move right cuz well I wonder
yeah oh no hang on for a second pawn
takes pawn Queen takes is not good
because of Knight takes Knight and if
Queen takes Queen Knight takes bishop
with check hmm so if pawn takes pawn
Knight takes maybe this could turn out
to be quite uncomfortable due to Bishop
e3 and all of a sudden I'm in a pin aha
this is probably okay then if Queen
takes again there'll be Knight take
seeds free if I'm calculating correctly
Queen takes Queen Knight takes bishop
with check you'll be up a minor piece
and after pawn takes pawn Knight takes
Bishop e6 a very annoying pin I don't
really see a way out of it he's
unprotected if he try to get out of the
pin and defend the knight I take with
the bishop you would take it the bishop
or even the Queen and you're defending
the knight on e4 so pawn takes pawn I
believe is still fine it may be best
right here it still I believe will be
quite awkward because you're
underdeveloped I'm already fully
developed and usually well not usually
but sometimes in an open position being
back just one move development wise can
really cause your whole position to
crumble but I guess this was still a
viable option at this point I would
probably consider strongly moves like a
five or a four
you know
and then there's just so much pressure
on this square where you probably have
to take then maybe my knight could
capture and think about the c5 square
still even if there's not going to be
some material loss as as was the case in
the game I think this is still a big
issue one one piece being out of play
can really hurt the position so this
structure here again knocking out that
bish huh but we had this only one open
file if you have control over it there's
no need to open up other ones that had
that one move sooner but okay I was just
boxing the night out and I got it one
move later and there wasn't really any
hope from that point on okay all right
good game finally we got the data game
in there mr. cube fanatic I pretty much
don't want to touch this pawn because
this night we'll have a fast track to
that square okay so I don't think I need
to grab and write just yet I think my
knight is going to be the one who's
better suited to do just that